-Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much going on
right now.
Supreme Court justice Stephen
Breyer is stepping down.
Everyone's talking about
"Encanto."
A winter hurricane might be
headed for the East Coast.
And Pizza Hut just released
its spiciest pizza ever.
Let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, Justice Breyer.
He's retiring after nearly
30 years on the Supreme Court.
Democrats are already talking
about who should replace him.
But you know who
they're not talking about?
Bruno.
"Encanto" is huge right now.
It's got an amazing soundtrack
by Lin-Manuel Miranda,
and two of the songs
are currently
in the Billboard Top 10.
The music is rocking everyone
like a...
hurricane.
That's right. A bomb cyclone
with the power of a hurricane
is headed for the Northeast.
And if you want to experience
your own personal bomb cyclone,
why not try...
Pizza Hut's new
Spicy Lover's Pizza?
It's their spiciest pizza ever.
With red jalapeños
and chili peppers.
It will mess you up so bad,
you'll have to...
retire.
Whoever fills Breyer's seat
will be stuck in that role
for years to come.
Speaking of things
getting stuck for years,
the "Encanto" soundtrack.
We're gonna be singing
these songs for a long time.
It's basically the new...
"Frozen."
To prepare, people are stocking
up on water and toilet paper,
but not because of the storm,
because they just tried...
Pizza Hut's new
Spicy Lover's Pizza.
In conclusion, time to go...
let it snow...
get that dough...
♪ We don't talk about Bruno,
no, no, no ♪
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]